radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green says
she was attacked at a restaurant she
tweeted quote I was attacked in a
restaurant tonight by an insane woman
and screamed at by her adult son they
had no respect for the restaurant or the
staff or the other people dining or
people like me who simply have different
political views they are self-righteous
insane and completely out of control
I was sitting at my table working with
my staff and never even noticed these
people until they turned into demons
people used to respect others even if
they had different views but not anymore
our country is gone
now there's a couple things here that I
think are important to say first of all
Marjorie Taylor green is a horrible
hypocrite here is video of her harassing
David Hogg about his activism out on the
street
flag laws
if there had been if Scott Peterson the
resource officer at Parkland had done
his job
then Nicholas Cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them why are you supporting
red flag gun laws that attack our Second
Amendment right right to remember oh
someone harassed me out in public which
I've also done to people you are using
kids to get as a barrier
do you not know how to defend your
stance
look I'm an American citizen I'm a gun
owner I have a concealed carry permit I
carry a gun with for protection for
myself and you are using your lobby
and the money behind it and the kids to
try to take away my Second Amendment
right
yourself
all right you get the picture so she's a
complete hypocrite nobody is allowed to
confront her but she's allowed to
confront other people and it's the same
thing as always I do think there is like
a serious
um
discussion
uh about the entire confronting people
in public thing now this has happened to
me many of you will remember about what
was it about a year and a half ago I was
confronted
um at a restaurant at an outdoor seating
Terrace I guess you would call it patio
at a restaurant where
um a young woman saw me and I could kind
of tell from across the room that that
uh she recognized me
and then as I was leaving I get onto the
sidewalk and at that point she yells
David pakman you Zionist Jew bastard
um and I ignored it
and just walked away I mean I'm aware of
it obviously because I told the story
but I didn't engage with it in any way
now had she done it while I was still
dining and having my beautiful fish and
chips which I had at that restaurant
um what would I have done I probably
still would have ignored her but I do
think that if you're at a restaurant and
you're actively harassing a patron it
would be completely reasonable for the
restaurant to say you can't behave that
way or you've got to leave right so if
in this situation where Marjorie Taylor
green was harassed she says attacked but
doesn't make any indication that there
was anything physical that happened but
she was harassed is what we could say it
would be perfectly reasonable for the
restaurant to say hey you can't yell in
here and you can't harass people so you
either you either got to shut up or
you've got to leave totally perfectly
reasonable when it comes to the the
difficulty every time we talk about this
is when it comes to elected officials
who earn salaries paid by the taxpayers
and who choose to evade
accountability of a certain type right
you can get to a point where in your
head you say the only way to confront
some of these people might be by doing
something like this now again I I'm not
saying I like this approach or that I am
necessarily against it I think it's a
difficult and complicated thing it's
it's come up when we talk about
protesting outside the homes of senators
or Supreme Court Justices and they're
sort of like the legal question but
there's also the moral and ethical thing
and I I I'm just not completely sure I
think there is some gray area but
specifically when we're talking about
elected officials whose salaries are
paid by taxpayers I understand that if
they make the decision that they are
going to hide from any kind of public
accountability
you can end up in a situation where you
say there's no way to even get my point
across to this elected official whose
salary I pay with my taxes other than
going up to them in public now going up
to them in public and screaming insults
if that's what happened not particularly
productive or or effective so let me
know your thoughts about this
um but the the term attacked that
Marjorie Taylor green is using at least
by everything I've read appears to be a
bit of an exaggeration
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you 20
off go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman
the link is down below